hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
course schedule two and if you haven't
already seen i've actually solved the
first one which i recommend
watching that video or at least solving
that problem before you try to solve
this one it's a little bit more
difficult
but it's also very similar so we are
again given
n courses labeled from 0 to n minus 1
and these are basically going to be the
nodes in our graphs so this is a graph
problem and again some courses have
prerequisites
so course a has a prerequisite of course
b and what that means is you have to
take
course b before you take course a so
that's pretty intuitive right
and so instead of knowing if we can take
every single course
in this problem we want to know for all
of the courses
and all of the prerequisites that we're
given we want to return the order
of courses that we would take in order
to finish
all the courses so we care about the
order but there's one little subtlety
it's possible that we can't take
all courses given the prerequisites so
if it's
not possible we have to return an empty
array so we have to
we have to determine if it's even
possible and then we have to return the
order
so this example is pretty simple we're
given two courses zero
and one and the prerequisite is so in
order to take course one
we have to first take course zero so
then in that case what's the order
of course we have to take zero first and
then course one
so the output is going to be zero one
which is exactly what we have
over here now what if i added one more
prerequisite so what if i said
okay to take course zero we are required
to take
course one as well what does that mean
that means
okay the first prereq tells us that to
take
course one we have to take course zero
and the second one tells us to take
course zero we have to take
course one now look at this is it
possible to take
these courses it's not to take course
zero we have to take course one to take
course one we have to take course zero
there's no
valid order so we return an empty array
and we know to return an empty array
because
we have a cycle in
this graph right there's a cycle that
tells us that it's not possible
so now let's actually look at the
general algorithm for it and it's
actually
topological sort this is a standard
graph algorithm but you actually
don't even need to know what this
algorithm is when you solve this problem
this
problem actually teaches you what
topological sort
is so similar to course schedule one
what we're gonna
do is starting at every single node
we're gonna run
depth first search on the node so let's
start at node zero let's run depth first
search on it
to do that we would before we do that we
would need to build an adjacency list
so for each node we would need to know
its neighbors
so for course 0 we would need its
neighbors which are going to be
1 and 2. basically it's prerequisites
right that's going to be
the prereq map so it's an adjacency list
so i'm just going to quickly write that
down
so now we have our prereq map right it
tells us for each
node what are the prerequisites so zero
right has two prerequisites one and two
because it has two
outgoing edges to one and two
one has a single prerequisite three two
has
no prerequisites right because look it
has two incoming edges but it does not
have any
outgoing edges so it does not have any
prerequisites three has a single
prerequisite of two
four has a single prerequisite of zero
and
five also has a single prerequisite of
zero
and so we are going to build the output
we're gonna do depth for search
starting at every single node and
remember the output we're trying to
build is the order
in which we can take courses so just by
looking at it you can tell
okay zero has two prerequisites one and
two
so of course we're gonna need to take
one and two before we end up taking
zero but let me show you the algorithm
so let's start at zero we don't update
our output yet we want to take the
prerequisites
first so let's go to one of the
by which we can tell from our prereq map
so we're gonna be at node one right now
and
one has a single prerequisite three so
we're gonna need to take the prereq
before we can take
course three and now we see three has
a prereq of two a single prereq so all
we have to do is take
course two before we take three so now
we are
at course two and lovely that it does
not have
any prerequisites what does that mean
for us
so so far we've taken a path we've gone
from zero to one to three
all the way to two and now we don't have
any more prereqs
so we are allowed to take course two
right it does not have any prereqs we
can add it to our output so i'm going to
add
a 2 to our output and so what i'm going
to do now is
cross out 2 because we never have to
visit it
again because once we've added 2 to our
output we don't want to add
2 twice right there's no need to add a
course
to our output twice so i'm going to
cross it out
so we are never going to visit this node
again and now i'm going to in our depth
first search i'm going to go
back to where we came from we came from
this three
so now that three look it does not
three does not have any more prereqs
right we've already visited two
it doesn't have any more prereqs so we
can also
cross it out we never have to visit it
again and we
add it to our output and i'm just gonna
repeat this process
all the way along our green path that we
just
went along so we're gonna go back to one
one
we just visited three we are never gonna
visit it
and one has no prerequisites anymore so
we can add this
to our output and we go all the way back
to zero now hold on a second so look
zero has two prerequisites one and we
already visited one
but it has one more prereq two so
let's go to two but we see
right we already visited it we don't
have to do it again we can cross this
out
we can cross this out so in reality zero
does not have
any prerequisites remaining so what do
we do we add
zero to our output now in reality
our our algorithm is going to say okay
we ran depth first search on zero so now
we're going to run debt for search on
one but we know that we already did that
right we already recursively did that so
we don't have to do it
and actually before i forget since we
added zero to our output let's cross it
out so we ran debt for search on xero
we're gonna try to run debt for search
on one but we know we already did that
on
two but we know that we already did that
we're gonna try to run debt for search
on three
but we know that we already did that so
now we're going to try to run debt for
search on four which we haven't visited
yet
and let's just use our common sense from
just looking at the graph we can see
that okay
we need to take these courses in this
order two
three one zero what about four and five
technically they both have a single
prerequisite of zero right so once we
take zero
we can take four and five but we can do
it in
any order right we can take four or five
or we can take
five four it doesn't matter because
these courses aren't a prerequisite of
each other
but the way our algorithm is gonna work
we are gonna start
in order so we're gonna go at four we're
gonna see
it has a single prerequisite of zero
right we can see that in our prereq map
and we know we know that we already took
course two so we can also say okay
course four has also been taken we've
done the prerequisites we can take
course four and we're going to do the
exact same thing with five now we're
going to try to see look it has a single
prorack
zero we've already done that so now
we're allowed to take
course five so this is the topological
sort of this graph and we know that the
topological sort is not necessarily
unique right like this
could have been a five and a four so
it's not unique
and we also know that if we detect any
cycles
we have to return an empty list
because because that means that a
topological sort
is not even possible and by the way
since we are visiting
every single node and every single
vertex or rather every single edge right
we have to travel along
every single edge i think at least twice
and we're probably gonna visit every
single node
up to two times so it is going to be
a so the time complexity is going to be
the number
of edges plus the number of
vertices or by vertices we also mean
nodes
so we could also write this as o of p
where p is the number of prerequisites
which is actually the number of
edges and plus n where n
is the number of courses which is also
equal to the number of vertices
and one last thing how would we actually
detect a
cycle like with our algorithm well let's
say we had a
cycle so let's say two actually did have
an outgoing node and it had a node
all the way to zero in that case what
our algorithm would do is okay we're
starting at zero we're gonna go
to one just like we did previously then
we're gonna go to three just like we did
previously then we're gonna go to two
just like we did previously and then
lastly
starting at two we're gonna go to its
only outgoing edge which is at zero
and at that point what our algorithm is
gonna do is it's gonna see okay
we started at zero we remember that
this is the path that we've taken we
went all the way
around and we landed back at zero so
this means we have a cycle
that means we stop our algorithm
immediately and return an
empty list we do not have to continue
and the way
i'm gonna handle this is i'm gonna use a
hash set
and with the hash set i'm going to
basically remember our current
path so we were we know we can recognize
when we detect a cycle so now let me
actually show you the code
okay so now let's write the code the
first thing we want to do is build an
adjacency list with the prereq
so i'm going to do that prereq and in
some python what i'm going to initially
do
is for every course i'm going to map it
to an empty list so initially it's going
to be
a empty list of prerequisites and now
i'm actually going to fill it in so
we're going to
iterate through every single course
prereq
pair in our prerequisites list that
we're given
so for this pair in our prerequisites
list
i'm going to say prereq of this course
let's add that to our list so append it
to our list and this might not have been
clear from
my picture but a course has three
possible states one where it's already
visited right that's where i crossed it
out in red it's already been added to
the output
it's been visited we do not have to ever
consider it again
the next state is visiting
right so it's currently being visited
that's the green path and that's what's
going to allow us to detect
if we have a cycle and the last is
unvisited meaning a course has not been
added to the output and it's not
currently along
the the visited path so that's that's
pretty self-explanatory
so i'm going to obviously create an
output list which is going to be empty
i'm also going to have
two sets one visit set and one cycle set
so these sets are going to allow us to
know if a
node or course has already been visited
or if it's currently
along the given path which this is the
cycle is obviously going to let us know
is going to help us detect cycles now
i'm going to define
our depth first search function i'm as
you can see i'm doing it inside of
another function
basically so i don't have to pass all
these parameters
into this and all of these variables
will be accessible
inside this function so the only thing i
have to pass in is the course number
that we're currently visiting so the
first thing i want to do is detect a
cycle so if this course
is already inside of our cycle set that
means we're visiting
it twice that means we've detected a
cycle that means
we're going to return false and then
we're going to be able to
terminate our algorithm and return an
empty list if a course has already been
visited
that basically means we don't need to
visit it twice
so i'm going to return true we're not
going to you know stop our algorithm
and return an empty list but we don't
need to visit this course
twice now i'm going to recursively run
debt for a search but before we do that
we do have to add this course to our
cycle we want to be able to know
if we have a cycle so if we ever see
this course again
you know recursively we'll know that we
detected a cycle but for now we're going
to go through
every prerequisite of this course so
from our prerequisite map
we're going to get all of the
prerequisites we're going to run
recursively depth first search on this
prerequisite
and if that returns false because we
know we have two return values true and
false
if it returns false we know we just
detected a
cycle so in that case if this equals
false we have to
also return false if it doesn't equal
false it equals true then we're just
going to continue
to go through all the prerequisites and
continue to
run up for search and when all of that
is said and done
we will take from our cycle we're going
to remove the course because it's no
longer
along the path that we're going so we
can remove it from
cycle we can also add it to visit
because we just
went through this course and we went
through all of its prerequisites
therefore we can say that it's been
visited
and since this course has been visited
we can finally
add it to our output which was our
ultimate
goal so we can add it to our output
because we just
went through all of its prerequisites
and from those prerequisites we just
added them to our output
so now we are allowed to add this course
to our output
we can only add a course after we've
added its prerequisites right
and since we added this to our output we
know it's a course we're allowed to take
so we can return true not false we're
going to return true
everything was fine because since we're
returning true we know that this never
executed so we never had to return false
we ultimately returned true so now we've
basically written
all the code that we need we just have
to execute it so
we have to go through every
course in the given number of courses
and we're going to do it in order but
you technically could do it in
any order and what we're going to do is
run debt first search on every single
course
but we do have to check if the return
value
of any of these calls happens to be
false what that means is we detected a
cycle
and what that means is we are forced to
return an
empty list we're not going to return
output we're going to return an
empty list because we because it's
impossible to take the given courses
but if this never executes meaning the
debt for search
never detected a cycle this will never
this will never execute and the loop
will be finished running
and when that happens we know we can
return the output that we spent all our
time building
and the output will be in the order that
we want it to be
so that's the algorithm let me delete
these comments so you can see the entire
code
on one page so this is the entire code
i'm gonna run it and show you that it is
pretty efficient
okay whoops one little bug output is a
list
so the function to add elements to a
list is actually append
so with that working hopefully i don't
have any other typos and yes
you can see that this is a very
efficient algorithm
this is topological sort but you might
not even recognize that
and there are different ways to write
this so i prefer writing it like this
because
it keeps things pretty simple right we
only have two sets we don't have to
remember
colors or other ways of solving this
problem
but i hope it was helpful if you enjoyed
please like and subscribe it supports
the channel
a lot and i'll hopefully see you pretty
soon